all'inizio dei miei video che la gente
se ne va zitto ed aggiungere gara della
mattina un attimo e fa centro e ragazzi
in secondo appello a tutti i ragazzi
benvenuti che sono video sono fa vj oggi
siamo su venerdì 13 anche per chi è
passato halloween quindi abbiamo tutti
acquisito dei poteri horror
quindi oggi scortiamo pietro non me ne
frega di essere jason o meno sei pronto
soldato speed pack che rimarcava meglio
dato che si chiama si chiamava a pakrac
e il jason credo di essere io
come noto a al 50 per cento savoia dai
facciamo anche un 75 ma facciamo anche
100 dai ti voglio bene 9 mamma mi piace
questo gioco online ea noi ti diamo la
regala ultimamente sono sempre jason non
so perché serie che si è preso allora
stai zitto che devo staccare i coltelli
della casa e ti devo triturare anche il
cugino 42 pt meglio non uno ma non stai
zitto ora vediamo subito avete due
barche hanno una barca è una macchina
quindi ne monti sulla macchina allora
trappola number one
e questa la piazziamo allo ragazzi ve lo
dico perché molti me lo chiedono ma il
mio jason
ha delle particolarità la prima è che
non corre che è un malus devastante però
è più forte in altre cose ad esempio
credo di poter sfondare le porte con la
testa almeno è vero te lo giuro questo
secondo alla corda quando hai un bello
sport
non so come ho fatto le altre volte
prati giro che con le testate entrava
nel tempo magari una roba che video
sbloccare va bene ok
salve giorno c'è qualcuno qua sul serio
salve è tutto a posto
sì ma abbiamo un deficiente 26 come fa a
essere così stupido questo serve buona
gita media stato facilissimo incidono ci
ha messo un secondo mi sta roba
alla cena tipo di spaccare addirittura i
muri non la sapevo sta roba va bene il
primo è andato matti col prossimo dove
pietro dai in una casa e zitto provo a
sparare la casa a caso qua c'è sono
beccato alla casa giusta ciao ne dice
pagato già aiuto credo che si vada mi si
è pagato già che adesso si svagano si
muovevano nomi si muoverà più disperate
ma deve tantissimo
dove sei vieni qua chi è questo bellomo
salve come andiamo ai un bel fucile situ
quello che ha fucile no per spero di no
no intanto ti avrei ammazzato uguale
tartan xj6 dei sacri e a farsele scala a
beccando tramite la finestra col
coltello vediamo davvero come apple
magari sì se riusciva fa ste robe la
geniale amata totò sfondare la porta che
è aperta ad un mondo salve ottimo
utilizzo del fucile zia complimenti il
genio so chi aveva il coltello maledetto
è stupido ma no no no no no mi dispiace
zio mi dispiace così tanto di averti
colpito con un coltello nella schiena ma
mi sa che un po te lo meritavi madonna
che morte brutta ho fatto una cosa
bruttissima avete sentito lo sbeffeggio
anche ma dai
pietrino quando tocca a te lo sei mai 26
è amico mio 26
come non si inserì sicuramente ha fatto
io non ho sentito niente mentre abbiamo
nella macchina come possibile poiché
sappiamo a salve
un deficiente un deficit ragazzette dei
baretti stupidi ma ndo vai zio ma andò
mai how
com'è possibile com'è possibile sarà in
qualche modo ma sei tu che stai guidando
che palle salve my lai una macchina
pietro mai dare una marcia pietro no
sì ma no a salve marco è per forza senti
senti noi che poi fa tutto due allora
basta basta basta fare le cose basta
basta basta hai rotto le balle ma io mai
rotto ha terminato hai rotto le balle
hai rotto le balle ammazziamo pietro e
smetti a riusare gente nuda
porca vacca c'è insperato però di
scappare la mia un pochettino vedevo che
ci speravi ciao zio ha posto la gente
chi si butta dentro regate mi fa
scassare ma la macchina tratto può
ripartire no prof
seesmic iata non è vero a 1 e qui fuori
tra l'altro valente adesso come fai si è
bloccato è rimasto incastrato poverino
la chiesa si castrato anch'io ammazzalo
gesso quanto tempo mamma mia che
disastro che la bella è bellissimo
perché non riesce a muoversi rimasti
affrontato da me la macchina
anch'io sono rimasti cassato sono pagato
devo riuscire ad ucciderlo per non
riesca ad ucciderlo già dei problemi è
che adesso mi sono sbagliato
morì piglio ma perché posso farti una
domanda perché dio sceso non riesce a
prendere le persone trovate temi numero
lo doveva il video ne vai
ma dove vai se benigno io fatico proprio
a trovarla ma tu sei tutto miliardi simo
ciao beppe è ancora un altro andato mi
dispiace anche tommy jarvis che non sta
facendo niente sei disconnesso mi piace
troppo cosa si disconnettono perché si
vede che il corpo rimane stranissimo
inserisco ammettere la trappola qui in
modo tale che quando qualcuno provato a
salirci si becca la trappola sono il
piede preso
perfetta è morto pure lui raga potrei
fare il perfetto otto su otto nei un cd
no non è vero perché mi 18 slot mi dice
che ne uccisi otto sotto anche se non è
vero o no vabbè ho fatto il perfect game
senza fare il perfect game dai dammi la
mano dove sono gli altri di efficienti
come nella barca ok è vero
pensavo mi stessi mettendo miglia che
male
vieni fuori dalla barchetta vieni fuori
dalla barchetta fuori la bacchetta la
zia tutta forza
non è vero non ci voglio credere non ce
l'aveva veramente lo so che ora dove la
ok questo è successo aiuto non lo so se
l'alimento nell'acqua cosa vedendo non
nascondendo ucciso notizia non sono
affatto cento
adesso il cappotto la barca bellissima
ma può essere scesa a fuoco la germania
quanto è veloce e sceso in acqua
incredibile simone notevolissimo pensare
che sta per ammazzare la tizia bloom è
su due non è vero ma eri tu quello
l'accordo ma veramente non è vero
michael è rinato e ricoveri rinato
scusato miliardi sommi jarvis ma
maledendo nascosto dietro la casa come
se scapito della macchina ho tolto la
trappola un coltellino svizzero no ma
che subito a scappare
no non ci credo darà vale come possibile
ritmi jarvis e non me l'hai detto ma se
il deficiente da va a cagare due parti
una domanda bwin ci sono le cose strane
la prima è che io non riesco a uccidere
questa tizia non capisco il motivo di
telenapoli odore ma malaventura riferma
tirolo che ero anch'io e non riesco a
uccidere non riesca ucci va beh ma lei è
ferma perché non si muove in acqua poi
adesso lo faccio però perché non si
muove e non lo so è stupido questa è la
prima cosa la seconda cosa supremo tab
mi dice che ne ha uccisi 11 supporto
come su un altro giocatore gli ha uccisi
11 pronto sono bravo e non uccide come
se si fosse pagata ha capito ci sta
partita pagatissima mondo avrei
preferito è morta da sola di sorta di ne
porta di noi tu tu ucciso undici su 8
grande gioco non solo l'italiano a
minchia anche la matematica bene così
avrai altro giro altro game
ok perfetto la partenza è ottima
potresti essere tu a norma o meno ma la
voglia di andare subito insieme cercare
di essere vicino a me così facciamo le
cose insieme tipo vicino a me
nappi di triscina me nel mio vedo il mio
video questo stai zitto che i fari sono
al centro esatto della mappa a te per
perché sono nella casa sopra quali la
casa c'è una persona che ho capito
allora chiavi e quindi tanica e batteria
va bene è perfetta da te non vengo amico
vieni vieni
ma allora sei stupido salve
meno male che 6 di bella presenza non
dal vivo ma meno
nei videogiochi volta dobbiamo trovare
la batteria cerchiamo stramaledetta
batteria comunque incredibile che la
resistenza fisica di questi bradipi sia
di 0,3 secondi si e sarà tra una mamma
mia che triste occhio che si andava
musicali jazz ne va non c'è niente
tanica battute queste cose le fusibile
abusivi dolore bene anche questo cioè
facciamone un fusibile troviamo il posto
metterlo poi se anche la polizia
perfetto campone trovato il po e la
batteria o buono batteria però io guarda
che cosa ho in mano ma c'è anche tu per
fare potrebbe perdere per me perché io
ti ho regolazione di tipo 9 con questo
personaggio ma la macchina si è
schiantata sembra che si è schiantata se
riusciamo a trovare la banda la tanica
qui mica sarebbero veramente una cosa
più [__] del mondo cosa che noto
riuscire non riusciremo mai a trovarla
per una volta nella vita ti prego la
tanica ti prego ti permette di avere una
sega di miele oltre sole mettere
fusibile però davvero si si si
vai al metro possibile arrivo a fare qua
fuori e con fari a questa casa romana di
mare conteso da bari che lo sci tg3 fa
fuori 20 fusibile fuori chiesto tizio
inutile da al bene togliti la tanica la
sto mettendo io tranqui tranquillo
ok se dentro vai vai qui da guida pietro
guida come messi notizie si prega messi
nel messinese del messina messina
messina non è destino che belli
abbasserei madonna moron madonna madonna
ma
non può essere non puoi avere questi
problemi al cervello non esiste non è ma
io io io non ci voglio credere pietro
non ci voglio credere partiva vai vai
avanti che vuole distratto quali però
bravo mamma mia se non c'era lui guida
bene guida bene vai avanti guida bene
guida bene guida bene dritto sinistra di
guido io ho timido io sinistra anti anti
andò avanti avanti avanti tutto avanti
tutto avanti avete non si passerà
turismo vai avanti avanti avanti avanti
avanti dietro avanti mentre dai di
rientro dai pietro dal adesso aver
sofferto per essere più attraverso bene
bravo bravo pietro bravissimo bravissimo
così pietro così a scattare ci sono
schiantati subito dopo
insomma mi ha ancora chiuso abraham
eastwood ci siamo scappati il secondo
dopo che è stato bellissimo bridge è
finita la partita però poi si è vista la
macchina a schiantarsi va bene bravo
pietro si gioca così per una volta che
non fai una cagata non ci posso credere
ragazzi con quello di questi episodi di
venerdì 13 spero vi sia piaciuto abbiamo
fatto delle cose incredibili ammazzati
11 su otto nella prima partita una
seconda siamo fuggiti portava oppure
chiamare la polizia quindi tanta roba
io direi che ormai son diventati esperti
di questo gioco quindi meglio di così
non poteva venire questo video ragazzi
spero mi viene di seguito cose mi piace
molto mi piace anche ai social che viene
da giustiziare se siete riceviamo
ricordatevi di non schiantarvi subito
dopo essere scappati però quello che in
dettaglio va bene da ragazzi
[Musica]